today's clip is another one that does
need a little bit of a setup before i
just throw you in there richard dawkins
and i were talking about the rna world
hypothesis
the idea that rna or something like rna
was the first replicator to come into
existence rna is really cool because it
acts as an enzyme and as a template for
its own replication this means that not
only could it act as a gene early on but
it could also be a functional molecule
that could participate it could
participate in chemical reactions in the
environment that would help it survive
and replicate
to be clear most origin of life
researchers do not think that a pure
rna world existed what i mean by that is
that they don't think that it was
actually rna as we know it today that
was just replicating and evolving on the
early earth the origin of life was
likely far more messy than this
but sol spiegelman was a researcher who
started doing some really cool
experiments with chains of rna
in vitro evolution
evolution in the test tube with chains
of rna one of the things that his
experiments produced is a chain of rna
called spiegelman's monster
here's professor dawkins to tell you all
about it
fieldman had a a virus called q betas an
rna virus
says genes are entirely made of rna
and it needs an enzyme in order to
replicate its rna and this is called uh
cubita replicase
yes i'm going to read a paragraph from
the ancestors tale here spiegelman did
something wondrous he set a form of
evolution in motion in this wholly
artificial test tube world with no cells
involved at all
imagine is set up as a long row of test
tubes each containing cubita replicase
that's the enzyme and raw building
blocks but no rna no rna at all
he seeded the first tube with small
amounts of q beta rna and it duly
replicated lots more copies of itself
he then drew out a small sample of the
liquid and put a drop of it in the
second tube they've got a whole lot of
tubes one after another representing
generations when this had been going on
for a while spiegelman draw out a drop
from the second tube and see to the
third but virgin tube and so on
spiegelman sampled the rna in his tubes
as the generations as generations of
tubes went by and monitored its
properties including its potency in
infecting bacteria that these this
virus is a phage which means it's a
parasite of bacteria so it needs to
affect bacteria
and what he found was fascinating
the evolving rna became physically
smaller and smaller and at the same time
less and less infective when bacteria
were offered it didn't need to infect
bacteria because it was doing it all in
the test tube it was provided with the
necessary
um
way to live in the test tube
after 74 generations 74 tube generations
the typical rna molecule in the tube had
evolved
to a small fraction of the size of its
wild ancestor what was even more
remarkable is he if he did the
experiment several times he always
converged upon the same
uh
rna
which was called spiegelman's monster or
spiegelman's
mini variant
and then later
some german workers did a similar
experiment which was even more
remarkable under some conditions a test
tube containing no rna at all
just the raw materials for making rna
plus the q beta replicates enzyme
can spontaneously generate
self-replicating rna which under the
right circumstances will evolve to
become similar to spiegelman's monster
so here we have a beautiful example
of convergent evolution in a test tube
starting from
not quite nothing but something very
close to nothing
certainly there's absolutely no creator
involved there some people might think
oh well the rna got smaller it got
simpler um that's not really all that
interesting what actually happened is
that the the sequence evolved and
adapted to its new environment its new
environment had different requirements
than its environment when it was you
know part of the genome of a virus and
it adapted specifically to
those
requirements it optimized it it
optimizes it for its own replication
and
there's a wonderful paper by gerald
joyce called 40 years of in vitro
evolution and it's free online everyone
should read this it's amazing
but he goes over a bunch of follow-up
experiments they threw different
problems different challenges at these
evolving chains of rna and they would
they would increase in complexity quite
dramatically to accomplish all sorts of
things there was even a medication that
was evolved it was an evolved chain of
rna that's used as medicine
for for years it it would uh it prevents
the onset of
blindness and aging
we now have a
i think it's an antibody version of the
same drug that's easier to store and so
it's cheaper
so the rna one is no longer being used
but rnas i mean it's evolving chains of
rna it's
it can they can solve real problems
meaningful information emerges
simply as a consequence of replication
replication with mutations plus
selection it is very amazing and it
completely gives the lie to anybody to
think you have to have a creator
uh to to start these things off it
really does show with an increase in
complexity increase in adaptive
efficiency
as the generations go by
so that was just a clip for my
conversation with richard dawkins you
can see the whole thing there's a link
to that down below
subscribe to this channel if you enjoyed
it i upload clips pretty regularly talks
and conversations and presentations that
i've done on genetics and evolution and
i am gearing up to start doing weekly
videos again here that are completely
new completely fresh